the streets of karbala have been
decorated
people here are getting ready to mark
the day of ashura
the city which is central for shias in
iraq
is now the destination for millions to
mark the death of al-imam al-hussein
majid says he came all the way from la
mara city near the border with iran
to visit the imam's shrine
and millions of other shia muslims are
expected to arrive here despite the
risks of covet 19.
i have been taking the same tough
journey every year since the past 23
years in some parts we walk on foot for
long distances
armed groups attacked the visitors in
the area in the past
so security measures have been tightened
on the city's outskirts
iraqi security officials have set up
explosive detectors
and criminal investigation inspectors
conduct identity verification
people on cars are checked before
proceeding further
kerbela is still in crisis after a
gunman killed its maid last week
but security officials say it's an
individual criminal act
are not likely linked to a bigger plot
they've launched a campaign to prevent
any
through intelligence operations and air
surveillance we've apprehended dozens of
suspects
all administrative borders of karbala
are also secured by the army and the
popular mobilization forces
as crowds stream towards the shrines
volunteers are sanitizing them
while others get ready to prepare meals
zuhaire wakiel says
his father and other family members have
been providing meals to the visitors for
many years
this charity was started in 1947 to feed
the visitors of the shrines and later it
was also financed by some donors
the commemoration continues until
thursday and ends with a ritual
that led to a stampede
in the past
some of these mourners have been
sleeping here for days
praying this year's ashura
will pass without any incident
mahmoud abdullah al-jazeera
karbala